Isaacson Texas Isaac how are you you too
sir
how can I help well nobody sorry I'm 20
years old and they're with my parents
and I am I bought myself some land and I
recently I got a blow missed from work
so I got to pay off my like my truck and
so what I am doing as that's Mennonites
do we kind of start from the ground up
so what I'm doing is I'm trying to build
a little building on my property and I
need to know what's your opinion on how
I should fund it because I make thirty
two thousand year and my parents are
offering to help me with some of the
money but they want to put it on credit
card and I'm currently trying to help
them get out of debt so I don't want
them to put themselves with more debt
for my sake agree I wouldn't do this on
my own so what kind of a little building
are you wanting to put on this land you
wanting to live in it well yes it's a
small barn tight building I grew up in
one so it's it's actually much better
than a towns it's it's going to be well
furnished from the inside and everything
and so I'm building a little barn that I
can use as a building when I get married
next year what will it cost in that is
going to be around okay and you make
thirty two and you're 20 right yes what
do you do for a living
oh okay all right and that's what you
plan to do for the next several years
good and the so the land is a place to
live it is not something you're going to
be farming as a business 3 acres yeah ok
so it's just a place to to build you a
place to live ok well I mean what we
tell folks is if you're going to buy a
house or build a house either one and
that's what we're going to call this
that you know if you're
going to finance it make the payment no
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay and
I would never do that on credit cards
and so what are you talking about
spending on this house barn well already
I really thought a concrete plan which
my parents paid for they they basically
gave it to me because there's been
saving up for me for a couple years so
they already paid it for me
I have a concrete floor so the rest that
I'm gonna need is gonna be roughly about
20 grand okay all right well then you
save up all you can save up and you
borrow a little bit from the bank and
you pay it back really really fast it's
like a house payment or if the payments
no more than 1/4 of your take-home pay
and you put it on you know two or three
four year or five year deal and then you
pay it off sooner than that fast as you
possibly can work all you can and get it
cleaned up because if you have the whole
thing paid for sure to set up your new
marriage well